well thank you for coming Irish maybe
you should say thank you for staying in
between two powerful talks this one
won't be quite so heavy I don't think
that so basic outline this is going to
be first part review of linear algebra
101 we'll try to keep that short and
light and then some interesting
applications
I found may be surprising maybe novel
for dot product and cross product for
applications we've developed within
technical services for customers so it's
the general idea maybe just a tiny bit
of background I've done work with this
ever since Fortran and C C and C++ but
it's fun and Mathematica for sure so a
little review of vectors in RN ordered
triplet or ordered n tuples that we can
add element by element and scalar
multiply element by element and nicely
plus and lists do exactly this so they
do plus and times working on lists do
exactly what we need
but with these definitions and the fact
that we have a field acting on a group
with a nice distributive property we get
algebra vectors that lets us do out
algebra simple algebra operations like
we do in algebra 1 bond vectors so
that's very basic simple stuff there's
two ways of looking at the dot product
and they interplay nicely there's a
geometric coordinate free definition
where the dot product is the product of
the lengths of the vectors with the
cosine of the angle in between them and
in particular for vectors of length 1
the dot product gives us the cosine of
the angle between directly and we note
and maybe it's just a reminder when the
dot product is 0 we have angle of PI
over 2 or minus PI over 2 in other words
it's an orthogonality condition and
interestingly when the dot product is 1
between unit vector
they're in the same direction means
they're actually equal and when it's
minus one they're pointing in opposite
directions and that has some interesting
use actually other definition that's
compatible but unique based on what
Descartes discovered is we can compute
the dot product simply as a sum of
products of the corresponding elements
and of course dot and Mathematica does
that in particular for r3 it's listed
there but with that definition we can
define a norm or magnitude of the
vectors as the square of the dot product
and that turns our n into a metric space
so we get all the nice topological
things of neighborhoods and open sets
and continuity and eventually calculus
of most multivariable calculus but
that's not where we're going today at
all we're keeping things real simple for
those two definitions it means that when
we combine them we can determine at
least the cosine of the angle by the dot
product divided by the product of the
norms where we can use the coordinates
or dot to do the work and just a little
illustration of course as we sweep the
angle when it's one the magnitude is the
product of the magnitudes and when the
angles 90 degrees we get a 0.5 basic
reminders okay real simple applications
we can find the scalar projection of one
vector onto another that is the length
of the component of one vector lies in
the direction of the other simply as the
dot product of the first vector with the
unit vector in the other direction and
that's useful for coordinate
transformation that's kind of at the
heart of transforming coordinates the
vector projection is simply the scalar
projection scaled by the unit vector but
it has a nice attribute if you do the
little algebra you can compute the
vector projection that is the actual
component of one vector that lies in the
direction of another without taking a
square root
which is handy for performance and the
picture of course as I change the angle
the projection is maximum when they're
parallel the projection is minimum when
they're perpendicular it's just you can
think of it as the shadow of one vector
on the other ok the cross product is
unique in that it's only really defined
in r3 and fortunately a lot of the
geometry work that we do is in the 3d
world and that makes it handy
it's coordinate free definition is the
product of the magnitudes the magnitude
at least prior to the magnitudes times
the sine of the angle between which
means it goes to 0 when they're parallel
and that's a condition that indicates we
need to change something typically and
there's the definition and the first
little bit of Mathematica code proof of
orthogonality for the if we take the
cross product there's the algebra form
and if we take the dot product of each
of the original vectors we get 0 0
indicating that they're perpendicular ok
so some basic applications we can
project a point onto a parametric line
that is the set of all points some fixed
point Q plus multiples of a unit vector
in the direction of the line in a very
simple way it's just the scalar
projection of the difference between the
points that is the vector that goes from
Q to P projected scalar projector gives
me the length and vector projected give
me the component in that direction and
we can get distance points line with the
Pythagorean theorem on that that
triangle
okay so basic applications for planes we
can do distance or a point to plane very
very efficiently and we'll see how we
make use of that it's kind of the same
idea
we look at the difference between the
planes point Q and the point that's not
possibly not on the plane dotted with
the unit vector normal to the plane very
simple we can project a point on to a
plane simply by pushing it down by its
height above or below the plane nicely
this gives a signed distance positive
above the plane and negative below the
plane and intersecting a line with the
plane left talk about this a little
later it has a nice tight formulation
that we can actually discover using
Mathematica symbolic capability so a
nice full blown application real tight
code using cross-product and dot product
to intersect an ellipse with a plane
when you find the intersection point
between the axis and the plane the minor
axis is simply the cross product of the
planes normal vector with the cylinders
vector and then the major axis is
perpendicular to that and we can find
the length of the sum of the major axis
with just simple trig R divided by
cosine theta but we can get that with
the dot product so then we have a nice
parametric form of the ellipse where VX
and V Y are the basis vectors in the
plane of the lips
okay some real applications this one is
actually running downstairs we have a
problem of blocks of a soma cube and we
need to align them first step in making
this easy turns out to be putting normal
vectors at the center of every face and
so we're given a command something like
connect the first block 0 cube face 4
which is on the back side over here to
face 4 to block wise cube 0 phase 3
which is down here on the bottom it was
couldn't be a hard problem but it turns
out it's not we just look at the
symmetric group s3 or the cube group it
only has 24 matrices in it representing
the 24 possible orientations of cubes
that line up and then we simply select
from that group the ones that have face
vectors that dot 2 negative 1 in other
words they're anti parallel that was 50
or 60 lines of code when we took the
project over one line in Mathematica
figure that out and then we still have a
rotational degree of freedom so we
select we have to line the faces up
north to north and then rotate them by
the commanded relative orientation and
so we get blocks though the face vectors
point in the right direction and they're
lined up very nicely and then the last
step of course is looking at the to face
points and bringing them into alignment
so a nice little application of dot
products and cross products
another interesting one we came across
before we had region intersect working
fully efficiently find the intersection
of a plane with a a mesh object it turns
out you have to look at all the points
all the vertices in the mesh but you
want to do that in a way that's very
light and what we ended up doing is
simply looking at the sign of the
distance of the vertices from the plane
and making sure that the only ones we
selected out of the vertices were ones
where some of the points were above the
plane some were below and that again is
a nice one line solution I don't know
why my pictures not showing up
there we go okay
so there's the vertices selected the
polygon selected whose vertices are on
both sides of the plane and so we
reduced the difficult problem to a
simple problem
okay so now we simply intersect those
polygons the line edges of those
polygons to find the loops in the plane
and
yeah so there's our sliced Triceratops
and of course now that we know where
those intersection lines are polygons
that are constructed that way we could
cut there and we actually do in the
application and similar techniques you
can actually intersect the cylinder with
a general mesh object
yeah
we can play the same trick to select the
polygons of interest by looking at their
distance from the cylinder axis which is
again the chief calculation and
selecting the ones with the right radius
and then performing the lines
intersection
another little application that we came
across
not heavy use of vector geometry but
simulating a fabry-perot interferometer
for a customer where the two variables
are the angle C the ya the angular
relative angle between the two prism
elements and the distance between them
that was nice and easy in Mathematica
code as well the basic components of
this or refraction and reflection and of
course we use the cross product to build
up the normal vectors to the surfaces in
an efficient way
a development method note this turned
out to work sometimes if we have a
layered set of functions nested
functions where we call the outer
function with symbolic vectors and
scalars nice thing about Mathematica can
do this we get typically a fairly ugly
symbolic result but we can then apply
full simplify to the symbolic result and
then redefine the outer function using
the simplified algebra that's how one of
the functions back there was discovered
and then once you have a nice clean fast
simplified function we can then further
enhance performance with compile because
typically we're working in our n real
numbers and also take advantage of
parallelization note on that though
you've probably heard that parallelized
talks for the application where we were
intersecting meshes it turned out that
moving the mesh across the kernel
boundary is more expensive than the gain
you get by kernel izing but if you have
a bunch of computations on a large mesh
you can move the mesh once the sub
criminals and take advantage of
parallelization with these kind of
methods
okay where does this all fit well the
Wolfram language has a rich set of
built-in geometric functions and
capabilities probably aware so it
defines all kinds of built-in objects
for solid geometry including cylinders
and cones and all of these and also has
a fairly rich set of operations of
geometric regions including the
newly-released region boolean operations
region intersect region union etc these
are very powerful very complicated
algorithms but they solve the general
problem they it took a long time to
develop them according to the developers
I've spoken with so where does where my
efforts fit in very simply intelligent
use of the basic dot product and cross
product have significantly better
performance in limited cases then the
more general functions region
intersection etc and linear solve so my
plan is to continue the development of
this package we're currently using it
for customers through technical services
and it's proven more handy than I
expected so the other goal I have is to
integrate more functions from classical
geometry I've been doing this kind of
geometry in various languages for a long
time but there's some nice result like
parents formula for triangle area etc
etc and hopefully someday this might
actually be a package as part of
delivered part of Mathematica
that's all I have questions